we've got two left we've got two left
and then the thing comes up
you go right now we've got two left we
got one ball and we are going to throw
it can we do this
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang
buzz bug
sure
no
something's always wrong with you huh
somebody took a bite out of your hat or
what somebody somebody shot you in the
head what's up
and he starts off by saying something's
wrong with me no dude you're sick
oh yeah you cough and sneeze like four
times i'm literally not sick i just
sneezed dude
you know what dude you have allergies
i'm allergic to success
[Laughter]
i'm allergic
[Music]
you know what it reminds
dude get my voices back baby what if was
he gonna do karaoke again because i'm
ready
oh my god did it did your voice leave
yeah because i was i got covered and
then i have like a sinus and affected my
you know vocal cords well we can't be
having that i know but that's why i'm in
the shower i do vocal exercises in the
shower yeah because that's when the
steam hits it you can work it out yeah
wow you're right
wait where did you learn the vocal
exercises oh you just go to youtube oh
well i have my phone in the shower and i
just do what the guy says really yeah
what to get your voice back yeah to like
vocal warm-ups wow that's cute as [ __ ]
yeah i know i want to get it
i see you you're gonna be in the shower
is that what it is yeah
you do like it because like a 20-minute
vocal ex and it
knows about this yeah you do it before
shows yeah before shows and stuff it's
good for like even before comedy shows
to warm up your voice
the actors go ketchup mustard ketchup
mustard yeah do they do that one i know
they do
well we hate we used to do
we used to do mayo mayo mayo
and you just go as high as you can when
you say we who's weak so you don't
notice but chris you should be like
tupac he went to like juilliard
baltimore no not baltimore but he went
to baltimore no i i like to do uh i used
to do like uh singing bro i i did
singing lessons straight up solo singing
lessons for
years four years yeah you can kind of
sing that makes sense but you know why
we don't know it's a secret life his
parents were actually monsters and they
like they want they they were like it
was like a little league dad he was like
get in here and learn how to sing
you're gonna act you're gonna sing it
would have been nice
you know what you know what i've been
not remember remember when they were
like remember remember when i everyone
always would say like when i was a kid
older people would say like you should
get in learn into some instruments and
they would always say like i wish i
learned my parents made me learn the
piano and [ __ ] like that bro
here i am 41. i'm glad i don't know the
[ __ ] piano dude ooh i wish i knew
that i regret i my mom was a classic
pianist really oh damn yeah she was she
wanted to and like her life was derailed
it's a whole kind of thing you know what
i mean so she would never be she was
never
achieved that goal of being a concert
pianist but she could still play but she
could still play you know not now with
dementia but right she um well but she
like uh that's sad but okay yeah
it is what it is right still but she i
tried to learn she wanted me to learn a
piano but it was like forced on me and i
hated it i know i know but i regret that
so much if it's force it's tough i know
but i would i like
if i have kids and i want to i i have to
find a way i can get fun i saw this
quote about from bruce from bruce lee he
said like don't buy you don't buy your
kids things you never had teach them
things
you would never learn
you know and it was just like
interesting i'm just like thinking to
myself like oh that's true
bought me and my brother's saxophone but
it was just like here
and then
like lisa simpson just [ __ ] yeah
before that's weird you're just like
here learn sex wait did you guys have
money when you were no that's a weird
gift saxophone and just yeah
like hockey gear like you know yeah yeah
just be like
you know like yeah we're gonna do thanks
pop yeah
i don't know he didn't want to learn i
mean i did but it's too
hard saxophone like a trumpet and those
kind of things are just so difficult
yeah yeah the nightmare um
yeah i said yeah but haven't you ever
been to a party
and like there's a piano and then that
one guy who like you know what i'm
saying oh he gets on
because you know what it is like all the
girls i don't care they yeah if you can
play an instrument
that's an end well it's like the guy
when you're at like chilling you know
you're in the backyard party whatever
the night is starting to get late and
just gets out the guitar no no
save tonight no no guitar is different
that guy should be beheaded yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah chris
no that guy should get 100 with you i
have a rule
but you know what the ladies do that
guy's getting his dicks up yeah i know
but but use you but use you to get your
dick sucked yeah don't use a [ __ ]
instrument you [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
especially not the one that all it takes
is like three chords and you can sing
like 50 000 songs here's the worst
though but no but here's the word the
piano is different it has more skill to
it i got a guy even worse than that the
guy who does the guitar right that then
does rapping with the guitar
beheaded dude i'll tell you what you
take a string off yeah okay then you tie
it around his neck so hard his head pops
off beheaded
yeah you kill him dude you know what i
think that that guy deserves to not eat
for three days i think that guy that the
the fair punishment is if you bring a
guitar out of the party where everyone's
having a good time right because we're
having a laugh it shuts things down it
shuts it down
today it's going to be the day
congratulations all good yeah but now
you can't eat for three days that's the
rule but also i'm gonna i'm gonna jump
in and sing with you because i know all
the songs no no no no no i don't drew
that guy all right how about this this
is the word like i remember you hear
that remember being on a set and uh uh
an extra
bra
so in like the air extra area you know
there's kind of a longer move somebody
in there
it's just like there's a difference
they're gonna kill yeah and they always
sing the same like three or four songs
you got harry connick jr there just like
good job dude
but there's either it's either
it's confidence
there's a fine line between confidence
and
just absolutely this person's brain is
broken to be doing this do you know what
i mean yeah it's also like you're not an
american idol dude well no like you're
not going to get you know
you know you're not going to hollywood
but here's the thing though there's a
difference between somebody who can play
five chords
and then a dude who picks up the guitar
yeah and he's just like tweeting yeah
yeah
dudes where it's like you're like
i'm just saying like because the common
person they you i mean i hear someone
sing and play because i'm like god man
no
but honestly to be fair you're a little
bit stupider than us and that's not the
truth
that's just not that that's not how
that's not how it's supposed to like
like mark the stupidity like i said
i appreciate a good talent man the party
is winding down
there's no energy and then he gets to
the catangas save tonight yeah that's
like dude you just revamped the party
vibes i don't know but that guy does it
too long though dude like he'll sing
like you want another one and you're
like no you did this song and then he's
just like closing time my favorite my
face
my favorites
no there's about four songs that they
hit it's all the four songs dude
uh it's awful yeah it's just too much
when it's camp fiery i'm out
yeah yeah yeah i'm out be near a
campfire that's when you do it yeah fine
but if it's like but i'm telling you
though if it's that spanish guitar guy
you know when he's hitting the [ __ ] like
you know where his fingers are doing
some [ __ ] where you're like oh man sure
yeah yeah
he he probably jacks yeah yeah you know
what i mean like when he's jacking up
he's tearing it up yeah by the way can i
ask a question before we start this yeah
i really wanted to ask you guys this is
a weird question but because a buddy of
mine was saying that like he's like
young dude he's only like 25 and a girl
came over and he him and his roommates
didn't have any more toilet paper yeah
so she used a napkin yeah sure and then
she says to him like oh so this means
that you don't you haven't wiped your
dick off after you pee oh weird okay you
know what i mean wipe my dick off boom
no you'd be lucky if i wet my ass yes
so you know so you like i've never like
when you finish
jiggle i don't even shake do you you
don't wipe your dick off with a little
piece of toilet paper then throw it away
never in my life
on this planet however
women think that we're doing this
she might be stupid oh yeah she might
just be a
dumbass yes she might just be done
so you two have never thought ever
i i mean no as a matter of fact if even
if it's still wet i put it in my pants i
got my pants i'll handle that yeah
that's what underwear is for yeah like
my girl make fun of me chris's underwear
on washing day it's just but that's bad
stains out of 10 days
dude do you know how many times like
just like the left side of my
underwear is just it's a piss central
bro yeah but you're the front of my
underwear yeah
six more years yeah you're gonna be like
like i always i from at 50 i'm like i
didn't finish peeing yeah you know what
i mean like it's a thing where you're
just like okay you get all
sit there for so long we're going to
watch a [ __ ] whole episode of like
how i met your mother
nah i remember my dad got so mad i came
i was like my sophomore year high school
and we came home late it came with my
buddies just to you know keep partying
and my dad answers the door at like one
in the morning and he's so pissed and
you know he's in bed and his hair's all
[ __ ] up my dad always wears whitey
tighties he had peepee standing in front
from my friends i go damn daddy i know
you have peepee stains
not smart he grabbed me by the [ __ ]
throat in front of my friends man
so intense and then you and then he was
this is the same guy that was like and
go play that this is why you never
learned a vocabulary yeah i thought the
same thing yeah i bought you a [ __ ]
sex that was that saxophone anger yeah
that's three o'clock in the morning he's
in there
yeah yeah yeah trying to learn it
do you know how hard the saxophone is
without lessons well yeah that's what
i'm saying yeah it's like freezing it's
like that you wasted your [ __ ] money
yeah well it's like trying to learn
stick and you probably found it you know
well no he did it right he figured it
out
did he just throw you in a ring one day
it was like get in there fight for your
life yeah you're a success bro yeah
joke's on you joke's on you dad thanks
for that saxophone dude uh
by the way before we even get into the
episode let's do the dates now no i'm
going to be in [ __ ] phoenix april
30th crystallia.com where are you at
like uh speakeasy or what are you
talking about here no celebrity theater
it's a
theater and it's going to be april 30th
uh phoenix so hit me up chrisley.com and
i'll be in irvine you know what's so
funny i might come to irvine we'll see
oh yeah we'll see yeah i want to go but
i'm gonna go to irvine i'll be there
with chris
stand up live what is that april 14th
16th
[Laughter]
i'm in arizona stand up live april 14th
through 16th
and then april 22nd through the 23rd i
am headlining the moon tower county
festival your boys in austin at the new
cap cities two shows friday two shows
saturday
and then also uh
april 28th we got a big special
announcement your boy's gonna be on
rogan dropping a special april 28th on
dick boy
it's really the lol comedy club los
angeles but i put lost comedy club where
is it that works too though this is san
antonio so i'll be in san diego and
houston so yeah that's kind of right
loves comedy the lost comedy club yeah
but it's really lol i got to change that
home and then i'm in improv in houston
april 14th where's the grand comedy club
in san diego oh it's just little place
man i love it i just did it that past
weekend it was great yeah yeah i saw you
just did it four shows it was great sold
him out it was that was nice all right
so phoenix crystallia.com anyway what
are we doing yeah
better that way special drops
that's very cool thank you thank you
yeah on your website on thickboy.com wow
that's cool youtube sick boy youtube
yeah yeah okay your boy went against the
grain yeah yeah that's good turn down
the big boy offers and put it on thick
bowl you gotta do it yeah talk too much
[ __ ] so something happened all right we
started the patreon and we the three of
us and sometimes the four of us were
having so much fun we wanted to sit in
the studio together and do more episodes
we miss each other we do and so what
we're doing is adding an extra free
episode correct correct so this is now
three episodes free and two on the
patreon on that patreon is lit and for
you guys that have subscribed you know
exactly what we're talking about yeah
that is so much fun thank you guys for
the support of the show it's an
expensive show to make and so we're
doing our best you know we're moving
through this as we go and we're excited
to
uh bring you an extra episode each month
so
that's awesome yes and for you guys that
have subscribed to the patreon we can't
thank you enough for making that thing a
success we love you guys let's keep that
thing moving
thank you two for doing the show
and yeah three episodes honestly three
two on patreon and honestly thanks for
the support no matter what if you're on
patreon great we love it we love doing
the patreon and it's so nice that you
are supporting the show in that way but
if you can't it's still awesome that you
[ __ ] watch us and we love that you
support us even on youtube or whatever
gang gang buzz buzz sure chris i don't
know about you doggie but be now that
i'm a dad yeah i know i'm getting older
because i care about my lawn it's green
my kids run on it there's no chemicals
on it anymore i i can be thankful that
sunday my friends at sunday they take
care of my green lawn you ever seen my
ficuses it looks like jumanji no i was
going to say beautiful do you live in a
rain forest yeah yeah i do it's all my
friends at sunday that's they can help
you grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty chemicals that's
great yeah man their custom plants
include a fertilizer everything you need
to easily take care of your lawn with
ingredients like seaweed iron molasses
you can feel good with the kids and the
pets crawling all over that place yep
all you have to do is visit
getsunday.com put in your address and
their lawn analysis tool
does the rest they do that and then they
use soil and climate data to create a
personal nutrient plan delivered to your
door when you need it do this the best
part you just attach the ready to use
pouch the garden hose spray away takes
15 minutes
do you hate having a great beautiful
green lawn okay
add our friends all right sunday is
offering you guys
the viewers and listening of king of
this thing in the wing 20 off it's got
to be thousands of dollars right it has
to be you would think if you want a
green line you're like this can be so
expensive nope full season plans start
just 129 buckaroos i like green grass i
got you daddy you can get 20 off that
check out when you get sunday.com
sting20
that's 20 off your custom planet
getsunday.comsting20
dude it's march madness fellas let's get
it it is march madness chris i know
you're a big basketball fan i love
betting can i do that you can do that
nick's priority doing it you can do it
with march madness you got duke at north
carolina get the big boys watch the
games make bank with draftkings
sportsbook turn your team's victory in
your own big win new customers can bet
five dollars on any team to win and get
200 dollars in free bets and villanova
too sure is it who knows no i've never
seen it or heard of it simply join um
if you everyone can play also uh
and if sportsbook isn't available in
your state you can still join the
college hoops action with draftkings
pools everyone can play free pools all
march long for a shot at a share
of over two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in prizes simply join a pool and
answer questions like who will make it
to the next round and who will hit the
most three pointers then track your
results download the draftkings
sportsbook app right now use promo code
kats bet five dollars on any college
hoops team to win you get 200 in free
bets if they do if you win
if they win we all win promo code cats
this week at draftkings sportsbook 21 or
older restrictions supplies see show
notes for details amen
going on guys i got a king interesting
it for you
trans women in sports i know you heard
about leah thomas
winning first place against other
females but let's be honest here if
brendan wants to fight somebody like
amanda nunez
is that okay
should sports just be integrated let me
know what you think gang gang buzz buzz
so nice um
you want me to go on this one yeah yeah
yeah yeah i i honestly think you're
probably the cleanup hitter on this one
you probably have a really strong
opinion
but i think i think that let's just
start it like this
dude
you you you can absolutely play you can
absolutely play but there needs to be
a
biological male deficit where they just
like hold your legs for a while while
the other women who started as women go
and then you you get the biological male
deficit and then they go okay and then a
guy blows another whistle or shoots
another gun and they go go
or you do it blindfolded or you just go
blind fair enough there's something
that's some disadvantage it's insane
okay here's to just that you know his
name was william thomas now it's leah
thomas he was ranked 462 as a male he's
the number she's the number one female
swimmer right now dude so think about
this there's a girl and she wrote a a
a whole essay to the ncaa went hey man
because leah thomas finished whatever
this certain place
i've been all-american i've been uh you
know part of the the picture my entire
college career my senior year i got
bumped out of being all-american i got
bumped out of be getting to the
collegiate finals by leah thomas now i
don't have a spot anymore that's where
it gets dicey yeah like and again leah
thomas dude 100 should be allowed to
compete compete against other
transgender
male to female swimmers
i know there's not a ton there'll be two
it's just not fair but it's just not
fair here's the thing take it eric first
thing first
can we it's like we're having a common
sense discussion about this
and it doesn't mean people are
transphobic because they have a question
about this and what pisses me off is
like you know what the [ __ ] we're
talking about yep so all the people out
there that are like oh you're
transphobic no we're not not at all
we're not at all here's the thing i have
two two points one
live your truth
so i'm glad you're living your truth but
two
swimming like that
it's not a it's not a right it's a
privilege
if you've decided to live your truth and
we and we don't have a uh a cap on what
to do with this stuff you don't get to
swim with other people
your ass should be at the ymca you know
if you want to swim [ __ ] go down to the
ymca why wmbc
whatever it is you don't get to like do
this anymore until we figure it out like
what you said you say ingest but it's
the truth you know in golf they have a
woman's tea yeah you know why yeah yeah
because men are stronger than women
right right right okay so they have a
woman's gendered male so what they need
to do is like have like they need to
figure out the the percentage and they
go okay so if you're a transgender woman
you get minus five yeah yeah yeah you
know whatever the seconds are yeah i
agree they should take from your total
time
like figure out like how you actually
finish fifth you could do difference in
world records yeah yeah finish figure
out what the thing is and then we'll be
like but we're not there yet
this [ __ ] is new no we're not yet and
like if you see a thing like that where
the dude is 465th as a man and then
first as a woman if you are sitting at
home thinking like okay i guess
something's up here if you don't see
that there's something up like what do
we do you know what i like though what i
like bananas i like it
everyone knows it's bananas
we all know it's crazy we all know this
isn't fair in any facet what i do love
about it is the left the especially far
left have gotten so out of control yeah
that now like when the voting comes it's
coming right midterms is coming then
elections are coming even the some of
the people on the left got pushed over
to the right like this is insane well
that's what happens we're out but that's
what happens like all they're doing is
people are pushing it even more now
that's why i have this thing
looking at tijuana like
i'm at the border baby
i'm at the border now i'm looking
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like chris's merch don't push me i put
it i told chris i said i didn't need to
push but that's the thing though it's
like it's like you've got all you've got
the whole spectrum you've got uh you've
got far right you've got right middle
left and then far left
these far left people are taking up so
much space and everyone in the middle
are going oh
okay okay okay and then all the other
get the [ __ ] button button downs and
those [ __ ] those rose pink shorts
that all the republicans have you know
what i mean those ones are that screams
my father's a lawyer
dude i'm getting those [ __ ] shorts
soon if you don't be quiet
you know what it's not even women it's
not even like they're taking up space
they're just so loud
like a big room and they're just over
there like hey
there's a lot of us on social media and
these corporations are bending to it but
they're realizing like even the left
like knew some and stuff like
and biden's like i didn't mean to fund
the police we need more you know
infrastructure those are the shorts
right there those are the shorts that's
what those are those are striped i want
the pure the pure pink what are they
called yeah is it salmon yeah salmon i
thought it was like carnation
eating its own tail man that's the thing
well you're kidding me because if you're
far left if you're far left let's say
you're far left and you're a woman and
you want to be supportive of all this
stuff you're also sitting there seeing
all these women
getting their ass beat by someone yeah
that used to be a biological man and and
their brains are going i don't know how
i how do i deal with this yes
you can't be the problem is you can't be
woke enough you just can't be woke
enough you can't be that's why it's like
you see amy schumer out there talking
about like oh well we shouldn't let
these people be in [ __ ] comedy and
this and that and like dude she has
[ __ ] horrible tweets in the past
she's having did you see her explanation
she goes the the interviewer goes well
you you know you have some pretty bad
stuff and you pass like the n word yes
yeah i know but i made up for that
because i marched for the blm yeah dude
all right cool okay so then so then if
you do that so that if you did better
then let other people do better dude
it's just it's just it's just it's just
so
it's just i know she's all women
and then she's post a picture with her
shirt off with her [ __ ] stamp or
whatever she can do more stuff with my
naked i can't believe the response i got
okay keep doing that
keep doing that though keep doing that
yeah we're all gonna pretend it's all
good yeah
i mean i you know it's like
it's a lot dude it's a lot and it's it
you can't be woke enough you know and
and if you keep that energy if you keep
that energy they'll come for you dude
they'll come for you but you know what
you know what it is though wokeness is
fluid
because what's good yes you're right
you're right what's gonna happen is it's
going to be woke to be against
transgender women yeah yeah that's going
to be now the right right right if
they're going to make that one come full
full yeah it's going to go full circle
it's going to be like and it's going to
be like a movement or people are going
to be like yeah but right now it's
pushing towards that because it like it
looks insane common sense common sense
takes over
and people look at this and they're
going ooh this don't feel right
and all i'm saying is like it's it's
like when somebody it's like you know if
you go like if i say hey there are
certain things when uh people are
looking for a woman right and then
they'll be and so if you have a
transgender woman who's like well i'm a
woman you go like hey do you know what i
mean how about this my wife and i are
looking for a surrogate
yeah yeah yeah right right right right
okay so um
well dude do you are you can can you
help me with that you don't know what i
mean when i'm saying yeah like we're not
being hateful it's not a hateful thing i
don't care i can't stand it like when
you get put into this box of like you
hate when you're just going like no
we're just trying to have a common sense
conversation and stuff that like we all
feel something about this
yeah
yeah yeah we got we got [ __ ] heavy
real estate it is exhausting sometimes
we got to get heavy in here dude yeah i
know sometimes we have to get heavy but
[ __ ] look at the pregnant man emoji
just go to the patreon if you want to
have silliness
i like it it keeps the patriarchy alive
men
ruling women's sports
[Laughter]
the thing that you're doing by the way
that's
what they're thinking
man they don't want to say it out loud
i'm telling you these woke people they
they
i'm telling you there are women out
there who are thinking like this
men are still [ __ ] everything oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah but even men are like we
don't co-science hilarious like dudes
are like no no they don't want to know
either the the the the like the trans
women like get up there and then they
win gold and [ __ ] and they're just like
thank you very much
thank you did you see the other three
girls who won bro they're all together
like
and that's the hard part about this leah
thomas though they do look exactly the
same
like that's the hard part yeah and
that's just optics i'm saying and it's
like i say but if you're gonna do it go
all in yeah no but my point is like
you're living your truth is
they did it like six months ago they
basically basically period this issue
and and uh macho man
won
you guys have ferraris yeah okay you
both have ferraris that'd be cool all
right if i put a prius body
if i take the ferrari body off and i put
a prius on it not for me the [ __ ] ain't
a prius
it's still a ferrari yeah yeah so in the
race yeah you can't be like
in the prius race like but i have a
prius bar but i feel like a prius like
yeah but you have the wiring of a
ferrari but the magazine you can tell
the priuses in the in all the races with
the prius and be like oh [ __ ] he won and
then everyone's just like huh well he's
got the breast prius and everyone's like
he's got a ferrari yeah but that's a
that's a ferrari engine but all the
prius supporters are like but it says
ferrari on the engine i know but he he
feels like he's a prius
and again let me just lastly just to say
yeah
i'm glad that leah thomas is living yeah
yeah yeah 100 percent oh yeah
that must have been supported it must
have been hard to like be like oh i
don't want to this is not me now you are
you yeah but like you it's a privilege
to swim competitively it's not a right
yeah
good point that's the best point
probably yeah speaking of privilege
listen one thing i would say about the
patreon one of the reasons we did the
patreon i was talking a few this morning
who's not here right now because i think
he's he started a new podcast with the
owner of jimmy johns in the bahamas but
um
one of the reasons we did the patreon
just so for everybody knows is you guys
got to realize when it comes to like
advertisers and the people who sell ads
on this stuff we deal with a lot of
stuff that you guys aren't aware of so
you know
not so much on my end but you know for
theo he had an episode that they didn't
agree with so sponsors go we're not
working with that show you're like wait
what it's not my opinions that's that
guy's been it's still theovancho they
went well we're not advertising on it
the first people to jump off chris when
his [ __ ] went down were advertisers
so by us going to patreon we we get rid
of all that man we get rid of all that
we control the entire narrative now with
ceo chris and i that's why we did it
that's the only reason we did it
there's nobody can say hey make sure you
do this make sure hey we're not gonna
work with this show because of this that
we're out man
we're gonna leave it up to the fans who
want to subscribe and pay six dollars a
month and get two free episodes
sometimes more than that because we do
bonus episodes and then you know we
don't have to deal with it
that's why we did it it's very clear
yeah i don't know if we gave that
message out clear enough that's why we
did it yeah it's a weird it's a weird
time out there i mean they they they
have you like cut certain like i have uh
you know friends they're like oh we have
to cut that part out because the [ __ ]
you know whatever it is whatever me
undies or whoever doesn't want to say
that or whatever it is and it's just
like a lot of it stemmed from the
episode theo did he's like dude i'm sick
of bound down with these advertisers i'm
like all right so what do you want to do
he's like if we go to patreon with you
me and chris chris you know the
advertisers are the first ones to
you know jump ship when he was going
through this [ __ ] i don't support it man
i said i don't either what do you want
to do that's where the idea of patreon
came from that's the only idea that it
came from
[Music]
we've got nick
she's got a kinder stinger
okay what's up girl
hi guys it's quinlan from florida and i
have a debate club for you looking
people up before you try and date them i
was interested in my neighbor so i set
my bumble radius to one mile and i
swiped until i found him
and then i found his instagram and his
tick tock and discovered he definitely
doesn't believe in women's equality he's
probably a brendan shop fan
then i found his twitter and his only
fans and he's doing some real devious
stuff on there
porn he's doing
bisexual stuff reading porn i mean
within five minutes of looking for him i
was watching another man lick his balls
so it was a lot i don't regret my
actions but i am wondering what you guys
think about looking somebody up before
you like that yeah
buzz buzz
is that that's him that's him
no no no no no
lady what's her name quinn quinn quinlan
be cool no no this is the the i can stop
all this
don't
swipe what what's which way is this good
way is it right don't swipe right on
that [ __ ] [ __ ] but she actually
met him in person in the building and
then she said it's her neighbor radius
and she found him i mean this guy look
at this [ __ ] guy well first of all
can i say is that gal from the street
fighter first of all no no here's the
thing this is don't judge a book by its
cover so she saw a guy that she was
interested in for shallow reasons well
she's attracted to him physically
there's nothing wrong with it
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that but what i'm saying is like
she wanted it to be what and then she
like did some research and found out oh
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that like the internet is great
it's like a dossier
yeah it would be like it would be like
if like in the day before the internet
you're at a bar you walk into somebody
and before you say hello you hand them a
file
here's my file yeah then they get to
look through it i'll be like oh you went
to school yeah yeah yeah i love your
pictures and then they go okay now we
can talk that the internet provides that
i have nothing wrong with you she should
have done that good for her yeah but
also she kind of dodged a bullet oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah nuts
guys
dude this guy would say
yeah no she he would he would have gave
it to her
she would have the best sex of her life
yeah but now there's gonna be a dude
sucking on his nuts she's like anyways
we've been dating for six weeks yeah
she's like anyways he's pretty awesome
yeah she doesn't randy's around all the
time and it sucks on his balls but we're
having a good time why is he randy
the widest name we could think of so
wait so that's but that woman is not
going to be going out with that guy no
you know hardcore so she doesn't regret
her decision and she maybe i feel like
if he still i think he can still get it
yeah i do too yeah that guy that guy
definitely could still get it yeah he
would just have to be like haha yeah you
know like he would just have to play
that [ __ ] you know and then she would be
like oh you know what i'm saying you
don't come over all the time
i hate to tell you ladies any guy and
only fans again is not socked on by
another man yeah i mean there's no dude
on only fans not doing a little gayness
you know yeah yeah yeah you gotta get
your nuts sucked down i wonder if that's
i wonder what women don't pay for only
fans no yeah true
like how many women are like actually
let me pay for some free the dude would
just be shopping on it yeah
ooh doesn't this look nice
we should i should get you you would be
like the only fans would have to be like
qvc you know yeah
but you got to check both boxes so
you're in home depot looking
door knobs we've got just getting your
nuts we've got my [ __ ] here yeah we've
got we've got a ball and you know what
can we do it we're going to throw in the
other ball just for [ __ ]
we're going to give him
can we do this we've got two left we've
got two left and then the thing comes up
we are going to throw in the other ball
we have never done this we have never
done this hey what i want to know is a
guy sucking on his nuts during only fans
do they get done is he trying to
negotiate the price you know like
obviously the guy's making money get his
nuts sucked you know is he like hey man
you know i need twenty percent though i
was a guy
yeah yeah yeah i sucked on your nuts
but who like of like all of his only
fans it's gotta be yeah it's guys yeah
ninety five percent well that's why i
talked about the guy there listen to me
sounds like a business you know what i
mean to me he's a business man
you know what i'm saying that's crazy
he's a businessman i i'm just saying
like it's like i just
getting back to it
he can still get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah i wonder if she was
like hard pass or she's like yeah he's
kind of a
but also demonstrating but don't say
that guy's a dime piece that guy's not a
dime piece yeah no he's stupid oh
god never mind all right what do we got
here
you know the boys are on patreon chris
and look let me just tell you we dropped
this episode right now you're seeing
today for the [ __ ] of it dude you know
what because we are we're givers dude
yeah dude we're givers and we wanted to
come in and we wanted to record an
episode
for the [ __ ] of it so we're giving you
the sauce for free we are dude monday
congratulations you have it and uh
but we wanted to add this ad in here we
want to add this in because we want you
guys to know who are on patreon and who
are following us on the free episodes on
youtube appreciate you on patreon we
love you guys people absolutely love you
dot com slash catsplus
you get the fire when you come there and
we'll drop bonus episodes not only for
free but also on patreon you never know
when they're gonna come but every month
they're gonna come some saucy sauce for
you some sausages for you and honestly
dude we just we we lo how much do we
love recording dude it's what we do we
love doing it better and we're doing
this to get on patreon so we can control
what we control and do what we want
because we've all between the three of
us theovonne the king the wing and
myself we've all had to bow down to the
man with the advertisers and you went
you know what we're sick of it yeah
we're gonna take matters in our own
hands and we think the fans are going to
ride for us and we see the subscription
on patreon you're riding all right it's
annoying when when certain sponsors or
whatever they say like can you cut this
part out we don't want to be it's it's
complete episode taken off of and and no
advertising and you know i've had the
issues you've had issues obviously the
three of us went you know what we're not
playing yeah we're not doing that we're
going to patreon yeah you get the raw
uncut [ __ ] on patreon so that's
patreon.comcatsplus
it's theovonne crystallia myself you can
only get the three of us all together
with the secret sauce on patreon thank
you guys for subscribing thank you guys
for watching and that's it go get you
some patreon enjoy this episode that we
did just for the [ __ ] of it secret sauce
people are losing their hair not me i
hope so i hope not
well people are man dude you want to
look like jada pika smith well you don't
i don't know you don't well then you
need dude more than 50 million bros in
the u.s suffer from male people
that's so dude i see my my meet and
greets i'm like dog y'all losing your
hair and what do they need what do they
need to get better dude they need keeps
they offer a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair
you meet with a doctor virtual doctor
we're talking about a real licensed
professional medication is delivered
straight to your door every three months
all right y'all pray in your hair back
chin bring that up
i don't know 24 7 care and support it's
low cost treatments are just ten dollars
a month all right uh it keeps us
everything you need to keep your hair
looking fantastic also prevention is the
thing right that's the thing if you
notice a little bit of hairs maybe
saying bye bye it's all about prevention
yeah it can take four to six months to
see results so act right now yup if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
cats to receive your first month of
treatment
for free that's k k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash k-a-t-s to get your first month
for free
keeps dot com slash cats
it's jack though yeah what's up gang
sammy j here aka dude with the eyes i
got a little debate club for you uh
recently ran into a girl i went to high
school with this is what i looked like
before
as you can see here
it wasn't popping for me in high school
yeah which brings me to the debate club
part it is uh hitting your peak in high
school or uh aging like fine wine oh
come on chris talking about i don't need
sunglasses man
you're getting old
i look at him oh cool that's awesome
that was recently no no that's that's
hollywood is it that that was recently
prove yeah
um well you're a dime piece well clearly
you you don't want your peak in high
school man like there was this kid i'm
not gonna say his name
dude he was the life of the party he was
good at lacrosse
gorgeous hair
i go back home and i'm shopping in king
super shout out to king supers and i'm
walking i see a guy falling like a like
a sweatsuit like not like a dope jogger
sweatsuit like traditional dad sweatsuit
gut
tummy sticking out jet here's [ __ ]
gun and he's following me i'm like what
the [ __ ] is happening right now and
finally goes bro remember me i'm like
absolutely not he's like come on
my name's blah blah
oh wow how are you doing yeah we're
talking
dime piece in high school yeah just get
all the chicks okay star team
now
looks like complete [ __ ] yeah here's the
thing guys
this ain't about peaking in high school
it's about not maintaining
kind of yes kind of but honestly because
there's a lot of people for the most
part for the most part this is about
like people don't realize that your body
changes your metabolism slows down like
people just don't maintain but but some
genetically like your hair loses we're
not we're taking we're not taking it to
but we're not you're yeah the hair thing
okay but we're not taking into account
the most important thing and that's the
height
height in in high school you can be five
nine five ten and a lady killer yeah but
when you're five nine
five eight five nine as a 40 year old
meatball drop that down
meatball
write it down
he's right though i was right you better
get it quick meatball
i don't know how old you're about but
you better get it quick because dude i
was like lanky bird-like [ __ ] yeah i
grew up fell into myself and oopsie
daisy i'm this now yeah right
so when i drive i'm moving it's like my
name is is that really him or who's that
because you see me like this with my
bulked-up shoulder
covering the [ __ ] out of my face okay
i'm a mystery in that window and that's
cool
that's cool i'm with chris on this i was
also a tall lanky guy myself i had a
[ __ ] tooth growing out of my [ __ ]
forehead yeah in high school now though
yeah daddy grew up yeah dude daddy grew
up and then you get out of the car
and it's better life's
better he's cool
nose in that window
then i roll up the window and
my nose it scratches
[Laughter]
but if you're five sixteen you got a
ferrari you're still five six oh [ __ ]
yeah but then they still remember the
ferrari oh yeah it's a good segue
because someone actually sent in a video
of chin before he hit his growth spurt
oh she used to be 300 growth spurt i had
my girls brother at 12. i mean i've been
6'3 for a long time oh you were the big
kid oh yeah that makes so much
that's true i thought that
oh
you guys have the same size head ain't
that a [ __ ] for him man yeah he had a
mustache at four years old holy crap
[ __ ] dude look at the [ __ ] eyes like
oh my god you're the same guy that's a
trip
i feel weird right now you should feel
weird
dude
yeah yeah well can we you know what's
the real sad part guys really is that
that was the [ __ ] like
like know that like we're talking about
men like how we cause like men get you
know older yeah you know what i mean
yeah like i'm probably more handsome now
than i've ever been in my entire life
but like you are a 50 year old woman
it's different you think leah thomas or
whatever will go back to man
that's actually the thing that they
could do that's the mood
stay good looking oh man you [ __ ] the
salt and pepper
get back in there get in your ferrari
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
unbelievable oh you know you know what i
don't okay this is the one do you guys
see do you guys ever see that kurt
cobain documentary
the one that it was from his diary yes
okay hbo so like one of the girls he was
like one there was a girl that like she
was this big heavy set woman you know
and she was like yeah you know i i was i
dated kirk
and i was like
oh [ __ ]
like they so then she was like showing a
picture of them back in the day and i
was like this did not end up well right
right right you know what i mean so it's
like that's what i'm saying about like
maintaining like people don't realize
that like you gotta like
when you're young you think you're gonna
be this way forever especially for white
people yeah
dart genetics are tough yeah you know
it's like you really gotta you turn it
like something happens you know what
it's just some black people look like
midwest midwest women too yeah they
start in high school they're like oh my
god and then they're just like all of a
sudden asians too cheese curds yeah it's
crazy but no it's all it's all about
like diet exercise and all this but also
it can maintain asians are about 70
they're just flawless you have no idea
they're either 21 or they're 70.
midnight hits and trying to [ __ ]
schmieger yeah but then they're really
wise yes
that's when they get wise and for some
reason they all own a market you know
yeah yeah yeah it's weird
let's figure that this guy's not going
to age very well at all yeah
he didn't peak
this is a maintenance thing again i mean
shave the beard yeah true true yeah well
he's got a big big nose those glasses
aren't flat
fan
i live in ogdensburg new york and
my little brother goes to
the middle school in our city
and he's been telling me how
kids are going to school dressed up as
furries
and they're like trying to make a whole
movement out of it
and now there's
school meetings about having litter
boxes in the bathrooms that the janitors
have to clean
oh wow no what's a furry
horde oh it's furry furry is where
people dress up like animals yeah they
think they're happy
they can only have sex even in middle
school dude if i took the [ __ ] in that
litter box yeah if i dropped a [ __ ]
coil in that little box
it'd be nuts no no no you know when some
poor dude has to clean up are they
because i feel like a fur i associate
that i'm a [ __ ] furry are they are
they actually [ __ ] in the in the box
yeah dude because that's the thing and
then they're kicking with their feet
like a cat because if they're gonna do
the the furry and have a play box that
they're gonna quote unquote [ __ ] in like
[ __ ] all that i'm not being a furry and
i'm going in and i'm gonna [ __ ] in their
goddamn box yeah i'm gonna show you guys
if you're gonna have that [ __ ] i'm gonna
squat on it and i'm gonna [ __ ] in it and
i'm gonna eat the worst [ __ ] and then
boom you get it you want to play the
furry game dude let's play the furry
yeah i'm gonna take it i'm gonna pay for
sandbox brown but then also keep that
same energy when lunch comes around
because you want to act like a cat you
want to be a big cat you're eating
[ __ ] raw meat [ __ ] how about that
and milk yup eating raw meat good point
yeah dude yeah be all in dude
[ __ ] eating raw meat [ __ ] but the real
question is like
you mean to tell me that to the school
has to like it's like
they're going too far with like you know
what we're allowing yeah what what the
[ __ ] well i get it though if people are
like you know my life so far you want to
do the whole you know uh uh
pronouns thing and all that stuff well
then everybody gets to do it everybody
gets to be like well i have my thing too
yeah yeah yeah my kid is a a dog
my kid is a giant rabbit
okay my kid's a giant rabbit and i want
to be respected well that kid's getting
[ __ ] carrots 24 7. i want my kids to
be respected as a giant rabbit so that's
what they have to do
it's your boy isaac spots coming from
jackson wyoming a little camera store
action here yeah i got a king
interesting for y'all today
going to the movie theater alone
especially as a grown ass man oh you
know i want to go see that new batman
movie looks dope i haven't been to the
movies movie theater in probably three
years me neither and i don't really have
anybody to go with and it just feels
kind of weird walking in alone you know
you stroll in and get your popcorn and
your snacks and everybody
it's only weird if you go to a
children's movie right but if you're
going to trolls three by yourself yeah
you pedophile but it's not if you're
going to batman by yourself yeah you're
awesome but also you have to walk in if
you're by yourself nowadays you have to
walk in you'll be like hi guys i'm here
alone i'm not here to shoot up the place
you've got to do that i'm just going to
be enjoying the film i would appreciate
i'm on the road
all the time yeah
when the first like i used to feel have
a there's like some kind of stigma like
going to a restaurant by yourself going
to a movie
man
ain't nothing better i'm at us when i go
to a city yeah i got a i got a steak
dinner i love it i got my ipad no i love
you with iphones
i'm in the [ __ ] so i don't talk to
nobody i'm nervous i'm enjoying myself
yeah
like a waiter comes over are you
enjoying it like yeah [ __ ] you don't
see me enjoying it nice dude
i mean you're facetiming your girl but i
like where you're headed no i'm not yeah
okay but even if he is that's okay he
could do what he wants your girl doesn't
went out by yourself
you're trying to lie you get to stay
dinner you're trying to turn it and get
it how you want it you know what i mean
you're all like boom boom boom boom dude
myself she's over here
you're just gonna like i just wanna
enjoy when i'm by myself i'll grab that
t-bone
yeah man there's nothing wrong that
that's a you need to go try it go try it
man go to when you're in a movie by
yourself you don't have to you're just
you got your snackies yeah you're
chilling
man talk i'm loving it by myself yeah
i would say i'd rather go with someone
else but i definitely yeah i think
that's cool that you go by yourself yeah
yeah yeah well i mean i only go to
movies when it's a kid movie with my
kids other than that well that's yeah
because that's what happened but when
you're on the road you
you go solo right you don't bring
sometimes i do okay you don't bring your
opener enough sometimes so would you
rather bring an opener yeah yeah yeah it
depends i don't want that one
like i had like me and dean del rey yeah
you know right yeah we were in this
movie it was this bill murray movie
saints something
saint vincent and at the end of the
movie man it's like this mother-son
thing and it's like you know
we just we're both crying yeah yeah
i mean he looks over yeah he looks over
at me like we're grown-ass [ __ ]
hilarious
so like you know but i'm saying
you know it is what it is what i'm
saying to this guy is like there's
nothing wrong you're not a psychopath
you go to a movie about no it's kind of
circumstances you're taking ownership
also
i think for me man we talk i talk so
much i'm sick of talking yeah if i can
go to a movie or a dinner by myself oh
it's ideal do you interrupt yourself
when you're at
i'll go oops
he just changes subjects in the middle
of easy he's just like this eating
popcorn he's like you bargains you know
what i like about this movie actually
you know what i thought about it
derailment
you know this you know what's cool about
this great people you know what i was
doing the other day wait a minute you
know what's weird is when i eat by
myself i still do advertise it
this dinner is brought to you by him god
this steak is amazing it's brought to
you by manscape
this cost me 150 i could have made it at
home with hello
yo what's up guys uh my name is andre
from northern california area
uh
so i got a king or sting it
golf
because a lot of my buddies are like oh
golf requires goofy pants and a fat ass
but
i don't have either of those and i'm a
pretty good golfer
so
you know some of the best deals are made
on the golf course but also
really expensive hobby so i mean not
like that's a concern for you
[ __ ] but anyways uh chris i saw
your [ __ ] on youtube about your golf
game
we'll just leave it at that so uh but
yeah can't understand it or wing it i
guess let's wing it like you'd give it a
go yeah i guess so you know you're just
gonna wing it it's like i'll try it but
give you guys a new segment you're
welcome thanks bubba yeah the looks of
his face i feel like he has a fat ass
you know what i'm saying like a big ass
yeah he said he didn't have a i think he
he baby got backs i think does anybody
hear golf you look like you golf nick no
never i get way too frustrated the thing
with golf is you just you can't try it's
such a commitment dude yeah any dad
that's a golfer you shitty dad you know
because it takes seven hours yeah
eighteen holes yeah also eighteen holes
do i'll do nine yeah this is you golfing
doing golfing yeah and this was the
first time that i golf and i was [ __ ]
i when i was they were going it was
going yard dude
i mean yeah it was pretty shitty yeah no
i was good looking come on bro oh my god
keep going but keep your head down they
were they were telling me not to keep
your head down the guy was telling me
not to [ __ ] swing all the way through
but i should have swung all the way
through if you fast forward it a little
bit you'll get to see me go a little bit
yard or in the beginning dude wait was
it yeah i mean i [ __ ] went far dude
come on dude that looks nice
you can pretend but that looks nice no i
don't want that at all
those jean shorts yeah yes yes let's not
wear them if you made yourself
whoopsie daisy you guys are wrong about
this are you are you johnny daisy what
are you johnny depps no i'm not johnny
depp i'm crystalia and crystalia wears
[ __ ]
half jeans dude and it's so ill and then
you're cutting yourself no no no no
those are all done i love and i and i
look great in them and there's no and
you can't those are those kristen's
changed
because it would be a little big on him
no golf i don't think golf takes too
much time yeah the thing about golf is
like when you first start golfing you
might go to one of these par 3 courses
it's only nine holes and it's like it's
only like not that long so you can kind
of have fun
but when you go to like one of these
like big five part
oh that makes sense to make nick get up
sorry nick um when you when you go to
one of those you realize this skill
level that you really have to have and
that's what makes it frustrating yeah
such a yeah it's so frustrating
it's like surfing you gotta you just you
don't try surfing yeah you gotta go all
the [ __ ] time dude yeah it's just too
frustrating yeah it's the difference
between like you know
and like you know you forgot got to move
it just a little bit and it's just very
technical in this [ __ ] it's too hard
and you're a bad dad if you're the first
time you smack that ball good yeah and
it's you see you go it's a great feeling
but yeah because i've done some like
celebrity golf
yeah and they stopped to invite me
because they got hammered and i'd start
doing the happy gilmore and they're like
well we can't have you back you know
you're a liability you're lost listen to
dad of the year over there if you golf
you're a bad dad yeah he's drunk on the
course right oh i got sloshed wow yeah i
have a drinking problem uh what do you
got naked uh we got a very unique rip my
drip
oh
okay is it just paint
is that paint or is that those actual
tattoos cause i see tattoos and paint
and then what that ass do baby
yeah a little bit of both god i love red
hair it's awesome oh you're a redhead
fan oh yeah 100 strawberry i don't know
bro just whatever
i don't you know hey
hey hey whatever that looks good
are you a redhead fan
no
really redheads and twins they're kind
of weird yeah really i hate twins oh
dude my arch nemesis growing up
redheads and twins man that's the
devil's work
never
but also her i've never seen red head
like this oh no redheads is that ariel
from little mermaid redheads to me
the hottest
is a redhead
yeah oh you
you have a problem huh oof
if you want to call it a problem oh
you've seen too many movies this is from
devil [ __ ]
this is one of those where it's like
there's hope yeah
too many movies alone bro do you think a
little mermaid did it for you as a kid
maybe you were jacking off to the murder
no no i don't know i don't know what it
is i've always loved uh redhead is just
the thing then yeah when he was jack
that's the first
that's the first
nah redhead that's the first redhead
tear your girl dire hair red though
we've talked about it you know i don't
know if she's gonna do it no no she
would but like i want her to be her
though you know i don't yeah but also
dye your hair red if that's your thing
um
maybe she did say it was the hottest
yeah and she's like chicken is it a
redhead yeah but yeah yeah yeah
but but but that's the thing you can
always go redhead like her her like also
like her skin tone would be great with
red hair on yeah but you need is but you
needed red here too oh i don't know i
never really thought about that yeah i
never thought disgusting yeah but i
think my girl has red hair but she has
like red [ __ ] hair really the color
ferrari red oh you're saying it's like a
pink red hair yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but that's more pink yeah yeah
no your colors but yeah yeah um so
anyway this chick but this jake but i
think being redhead and centeno is gonna
hate this it's actual uh it's they they
have like some issues right like they
can't be in the sun oh oh oh freckles
it's actually not a great thing yeah
well it's like
five risk of being a redhead you're more
sensitive to pain i [ __ ] knew it
you're angry all the time santino
increased parkinson risk i knew that
skin cancer risk really knew that
parkinson
parkinson's more skin birth marks show
and if and if you and if you are have a
mixed race marriage your kids just
oh should be put down
they look awesome
they come out the doctor's like
like red headed like redhead and black
oh man blake griffin you're blake
griffin yeah he's probably the only one
that's sort of handsome it's interesting
you brought him up nick because he has
some real issues with the law right now
but i think this dude yeah yeah uh
violent bob ross they call him i thought
that was i
i'm with chris a little bit on this
because i've never seen a red head like
that and she is a dime piece bro you've
never seen a red head like that like
what are you talking about i've never
seen an attractive redhead oh oh well
that's nice
oh name one
go i'll wait there's one there's one in
there
there's one in the wwf or ewe uh natural
redhead i don't now he's talking natural
i know how to talk about it it has to be
natural we're talking about you know
she's natural she's oh dude
so she's all woman all right
i can't even have this conversation it's
so you know why because you can't name
one no
name who's your natural rhetoric give me
a name who the [ __ ] knows i'll give you
one and help you out the girl from uh
she's zero dark thirty she's a dime
piece jessica chelsea oh yeah oh yeah
yeah exactly is she natural red i don't
know where yeah she's she's a decorator
literally she's one of the hottest
actresses there you go yeah okay well
that's right
also what about the [ __ ] one oh angie
everhart remember her
no well google
she's she's she's older isn't julia
roberts
bro look google and jabra heart isn't
julia roberts her redhead look at her i
don't know
julia roberts the redhead unicorns huh
they're hot as [ __ ]
well all of them
[ __ ] no not all of them dude no she's
not but she had this sort of looks
red-headed
yeah but well i had the best one right
because she's relevant yeah no auntie
ever
she looks like the chick from that one
kids movie the dragon one
insecure wow she's right that was good
it's behind those two pictures i'm jess
i'm 30 years old from montreal canada
and the pictures you see now are
pictures that i have recently posted up
on instagram for international women's
day
i recently had gone through a lot of
body trauma and
uh the whole concept was kind of like
war body paint to symbolize
you know the warrior within yeah
body trauma go on she has body trauma
and she's since she did it for war she
wants that's cool man yeah
dude take ownership of that ass yeah i
mean i look i mean you rip my drip it's
like you know she's wearing paint and
all that [ __ ] but she's just
it's not like she's going to mcdonald's
yeah there's nothing we can rip yeah
you're smoking so it's funny it's all
about fire it's all about perspective
too it's all about perspective or
whatever your intent is yeah because
like that same stuff could easily be on
only fans as she's selling for content
yeah but she'd have to be like touching
her [ __ ] necessarily you can't just
have paint on you you gotta be like oops
got paint on me see what's down here
gotta do like that so aggressive
it's not me who's doing it it's these
[ __ ] only fantasy we don't know maybe
she could do only fans yeah she could do
it but hire the guy to suck on balls
you just have to you just have to
only be a chick and you can be on only
fans it doesn't matter how attractive
you are or what paint you're wearing or
clothes you're wearing you could just be
on only fans period but what was she
asking i don't know this segment she
wants to rip her drip but she's a smoke
show redhead with body paint on she
looks gorgeous
what's her perspective oh my rip my drip
is a segment where people send in their
outfits and then we would rip them it's
never really went anywhere i've always
kind of hated it but people keep sending
them in so it's okay it's good
because she's a dying piece and she also
i support russia and the war so i put
pain all over my body so it's kind of
strange
people are now i'm saving people's lives
yes putting handprints on my titties
i'll donate right now
whatever
she might be for russia better red than
debt
that was my point nick rehired rehired
back in
whatever
she's gone through you look like you're
doing great yeah and uh more power to
you and it looks great you're all fans
here but also
don't
her disposition and her attitude is so i
know uh sweet yeah and positive yeah
yeah she's killing it yeah you're
killing it or whatever
you're
your
whatever traumas in the past look at
it's the real review mirror keep going
forward
[ __ ] in montreal are talking about
but you're crushing it yeah yeah yeah
yeah don't slap that page now this is
your producer in the other room yeah
yeah that's big mike yeah
that's the head of think boy big mike so
yeah by the way who has a hat with just
a general dog
what a [ __ ] lunatic what do you have
this is yeah
is this a is this a hey does he have
your hoodie
wait is that life is that a blank oh no
it no it's just like does it just say
thick rips what the [ __ ] when he says
thick ribs
it is okay okay
is the logo really low no you know what
it is you put the logo on your tummy now
you know what it is he's got an og one
that's the og one we made it a little
dark you can't see yep i like that one
i don't like that one nope
uh what's up fellas just sitting in my
car i know nick loves those car
submissions
um but last night i was hanging out with
my wife and i got a text message from my
buddy i laughed out loud she hit me with
the who are you texting
uh
then i got one of those weird
relationship questions about is he more
of your best friend than i am oh
absolutely kind of thinking because
that's different you know how we're
going to pretend that our girls are our
best friend the relationship i have with
her but she's obviously my best friend
that's why she's not though yeah she's
not going to do all the things together
and put a dick on her we'll see
everything i like
takes care of me and all that so the
bait club is my wife is my best friend
that's uh weird how do you guys feel i
mean dude here's the thing
davidoff's joke dude my best friend let
me [ __ ] other people you know
that's funny yeah dubs hilarious dude
all right look
like this here's the deal with this
shout out to dove
that's funny actually that's really
funny yeah david was [ __ ] hilarious
um
you you just you you
okay you got this yes
she is your best friend and of course
you live with her and you're in a good
relationship but just don't no just
don't say that
just have your best friend be your best
friend do you yeah it's like one of the
things that kristen said in the
beginning she was like you know what i
hate is like when when guys act like
their girlfriend is their best friend
and i go like this
you're the one because you get it you
got a pregnant right there but then yeah
but then later on
but then later on we were like winking
at each other and like we know that
we're the best friends you know but
though you know say it though no but
this is something different this guy was
enjoying something and his girl was like
wanted to be why don't you enjoy things
like that with me yeah do you when i
text you do you enjoy stuff like it's
like that's what this is really about
yeah look look women want you to build
something
women want to be in charge of joy of the
way you feel yeah you have jewelry yeah
and there could be no joy
unless they explicitly yeah already like
but it's written consent but it's also
like my best friend sent me a video of
someone
elbow deep in another man's ass
it was a joke
you've never said that
that's best friend talk yeah i i i hear
you there's different types of best
friends your girls send you like oh
check out this guy's balls that she got
to be a comedian
yeah yeah that's why you have different
relationships for different things
you're not my best friend and you're
welcome for that yes you don't want to
be my best friend that's what i'm saying
i think there's like you have different
relationships with different people for
that specific reason mm-hmm
it's okay it's okay that she's your best
friend
i like uh that hoodie though that zip up
that's raw gear i have the same hoodie
yeah i know you do shout to bradley
martin and this is gerald me shark
holy [ __ ] is it no it's not they're
identical oh my god well that guy looks
like the guy who i mean he looks like
the guy who didn't fight yet but yeah
he's canadian for sure 100 so
what's up theo what's up brandon what's
up chris i'm jacob
from cincinnati ohio and i actually work
at the liberty funny bone i'm sitting
outside of it right now cool i have a
king that are stinging for you comedy
clubs that are also restaurants
when i'm working every time i hear a
utensil or a plate or something like
that clang against a table i always am
curious if that bothers the comedians or
messes with their focus or anything like
that that's me nuts um so yeah i was
just wondering how you guys feel about
that huge fan of all of you guys uh gang
gang buzz buzz flap flap
i mean i know what it is it doesn't
bother me at all yeah i mean if it's if
you know what bothers me is if the
tables are circular and it's like
banquet style
that that sucks but not not if it's just
food and [ __ ] it's rare it's a problem
because people are coming early to eat
yeah yeah and then but like it's
terrible like if it's like in the middle
of the show
and you're hearing like wedding it's
like at the wedding time where people
like you yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's
never really like that no it's not
everybody you're trying to show they're
just enjoying themselves like when i get
on stage yeah if it's your show yeah
they've already done yeah yeah yeah yeah
and aren't some clubs better at like the
check drop and just being more described
you just got to give them your time it's
crazy the features doing this time i'm
doing this time so i know when to drop
the check i'm pretty sure my boy david
lucas opened for louis ck what he does
is he goes when i get off you drop the
check
which is kind of tough on the staff it's
real tough it's pretty tough because
they're there for a hot second it's
pretty tough to uh to do the check drop
it actually sucks yeah i don't even
think about like i try to pretend like
it doesn't matter enough like if you're
a good comic you can get through it and
you can but like it just it's crazy dude
the law it's a distraction yeah but i
hate like you know you're maybe you're
going into a bit that it's like there's
a significant set up yeah yeah there's
like there's a way and then like it's
always
it's always like the checks and you see
people not listening and you never mind
you're like you got to hear this part i
know that's so funny that's so funny you
need this party
yeah they're not gonna get it you missed
that it's almost like they should
stagger them i guess they kind of do but
it still [ __ ] it up is that craig
conant i was just gonna say is that
craig hey guys you can't get or stinging
what up chris brennan theo it's andrew
from north carolina
and i got a debate club for you guys
today
cutting someone's car oh
how [ __ ] is it to key someone's god
it's really fun to be an ex-girlfriend
yeah like this is gonna be the most
[ __ ] crime ever that's exhausting oh
[ __ ] girl boy's a nice guy he's got
no enemies yeah
let's be a girl daddy that sucks anyways
it's not really debate but i was just
thinking since i can't key this guy's
face myself it'd be nice to hear you
guys make fun of them think about
denny's you know give him a nice grand
slam hell yeah dude gang gang buzz buzz
sword wow this guy couldn't be more of a
[ __ ] crystal fan but um i love it i
love it i love it you thought
you thought brendan's fans were [ __ ]
catching up
get him right there i need that face on
your next life rip [ __ ] hoodie that's
it right there
dude
such a [ __ ]
especially if it's another guy
what god dude just come to my face dude
yeah it's like kicking somebody in the
balls yeah like what are you doing man
it's such a [ __ ] move yeah that's it's
exhausting to fix too and that thing's
all the panels yeah from front to back
well it's like when somebody breaks into
your car the worst part about it is when
they break the window so because then
you're like this is gonna co now i gotta
happen to me they did that to my car uh
about a month ago i gotta fix this
window i'd rather have a window than key
to like around like that that sucks i'd
rather have a brush
dude that that hurts my feelings that
that happened to that guy also that's a
cool color that's uh that's a yeah it
was a dark color
all i saw was the amount of money it's
going to cost to fix that it's
exhausting man you keep saying
exhausting he doesn't have to do it
but do you gotta take it to the shop i
did the energy yeah the energy the time
it's gonna take a hot second yeah it's
exhausting but that wasn't like a great
car but you know but still
it took it from a fine car to a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] with one key you know what
also who and the guy did is a coward
yeah he's a coward he's a cat you're a
[ __ ] up [ __ ] howard yeah you
assume it's a young kid like no there's
nothing no it's not a young kid it's a
coward yeah you're right like he should
have stepped to that guy like yeah you
shouldn't have done this yeah but it
could just be a vandal like somebody who
just did it for no reason that's so well
do you think it's mostly a personal
crime i think that's a yeah when you
keep personally it's
what it would be like
for your car to get keyed
you know what i mean
they really keep that thing
all right this is the last one who even
has keys it doesn't have the [ __ ]
before we watch it let's just watch and
i don't have mine one more time yeah
wow that's a great one
that's hilarious that's what i'm saying
i don't think he's in asia yeah he's
mexican for sure i mean no doubt dude
he's feeling it that's my favorite one
of all wow it's a small
small person yeah i can tell you that a
kid with a mustache
yo king in the sting fam what up man
just headed to work right now safety
first yeah uh got a king interesting yet
for you though destination weddings me
and my wife just got married in hawaii
kept a very small party
um didn't have my drunk ass uncle there
with his 22 year old girlfriend he's 56.
okay nice and yeah we just you know just
got it done over there so what do you
guys think destination weddings king or
st you two are getting married you you
take this first but i'm all about
destination weddings i wish i was having
one uh i went to a destination wedding i
went to adam devine's wedding and it was
fantastic
you know as a guest like being a guest
at a destination wedding is great
because you get the the discount at the
resort you're at
it's like it's like a little bit like a
vacation it's a vacation we went two
days early to really enjoy the fact it
was it was in cabo it was a really nice
one it was like the room we had was dope
and the price of that room was normally
like almost a thousand a night a
discount and we got a half off of that
so i was like let's say two extra days
so i'm saying i'm all about destination
weddings it's like you're on a vacation
and by the way we were in the pool and
it was all people i know and it was like
oh i've never actually been on vacation
with my friends yes and it was really
nice it was cool so i'm all about that
yeah there it is right there destination
weddings it was great why are you really
only one in a suit well it was like this
was like after this yeah uh nah dude you
want to go somewhere where your friends
go get a [ __ ] pizza
don't give me [ __ ] to do
yeah don't force it it's a lot of
pressure
there's no pressure it is though i gotta
go
or you don't go and you're a bad friend
oh yeah no no it's not
it's a out
you know it's an out man not really
though oh man yes it is because you two
are doing your wedding around the same
marriage i'm having my wedding on a
thursday because i want all my comic
friends to be like dude i booked a
weekend i'll be like it's totally okay
i don't i don't feel bad i don't know
everybody just send me a good gift i
want mine on the weekend mine's on the
weekend because i want it to be on the
weekend because when they don't come i
want to be mad yeah but you and your
fancy ass wedding with like the wedding
person that he sends like like you know
all these emails and now i got a book by
so i got to go on my honeymoon and i got
to come back
yeah
we're coming back on the 17th just to go
to your see what i'm saying it's [ __ ]
annoying it's not even a destination one
imagine if you have to go the nation one
you gotta be in combo because i still
gotta it's a long drive [ __ ] but
i feel like we're going to downtown but
we gotta get in the car i gotta stay at
a hotel no [ __ ] you're having a
destination [ __ ] you
this guy dude
is it downtown l.a no [ __ ] you having a
destination wedding no santa barbara you
can drive back that night
you better sell one of these ferraris
they better be open bar i don't even
drink and i'm gonna be foreign
it's me what you talking about come on
man yeah what's that mean you show up
you get all this [ __ ] it's all good it's
open bars gift baskets don't be the guy
that doesn't drink and then we don't
have to drink i went to weddings
bro how dare you think i'm not set up
oops
but by the way
you having a destination wedding okay
let's just say barbara's not destination
i'm driving back that's not from him i'm
driving back you go back that night i'm
going back that night
yeah you're gonna be dry you're gonna be
mad right and yours is where eric huh
where i got the it's actually if you're
here oh
yeah yeah yeah it's like that golf
course that's like you know
it's a golf course her parents are
paying for it so i'm like whatever you
want to do it yeah yeah yeah so that's
why it's on the thursday it's like
that's good yeah yeah
well i can't wait to go to yours yeah
it's gonna be simple it's gonna be quick
thank you gonna knock it out like this
yeah yeah yeah thank god those long ones
those long religious ones the catholic
ones [ __ ] all my girls
she wants to do some of the jewish
traditions
quick yeah to be quick we gotta pick her
up on the chair and [ __ ] no i'm gonna
get circumcised again so it's gonna be
okay
right before the right before the
wedding
i'm gonna pull it out
today guys gonna come to lambeau field
for mine
i'm single you gotta get a girl first
man let's one step at a time no because
nick's wedding like there's gonna be
gambling you know what i mean yeah it's
gonna be like a whole thing like a
casino there's over this will be over in
five years
okay
85. you know what
i know what it is there's something in
here um yeah they don't vacuum or
something oh really i feel fine
dude i i'll by the way i haven't coughed
the whole time i've been here i just
sneezed twice before the [ __ ] started
it's alarming dude
you're right we're at
and previously i'm worried about you i'm
worried about your health because
previously you had those those stomach
issues oh yeah 30 minutes later you have
that your skin is still you look white
atrocious no my skin's good dude i'll
tell you my skin's nice dude it's a nice
kind of like alabaster like chill kind
of like by the way in the [ __ ] 1600s
i would have been like the guy that
everyone was jealous of
oh yeah right but i look but that's this
is the thing it'd be like oh he's
indoors all the time he doesn't do field
work he's rich as [ __ ] yeah imagine how
many times i get sucked off do you have
uh
i don't remember that show i remember
that show there was what was that show
uh about the king of england you know
there was like like so he's like jacking
off and there's a guy holding oh oh you
told me about this shot yeah the guy's
holding uh he's like the come catcher
yeah awesome dude everybody had a
different kind of just something bro
you're like a terrible gig
that job is an honor dude
one day you could grow up to be a come
catcher like that's what uh but it's a
family business
so how do you teach your kid like you
have to like no not like that yeah don't
let it fall you don't have the king he
shoots ropes go this far yeah yeah i
want to see that show yeah what the show
is the tutors it was the tutors the
tutors the tutors
he just comes and gets halted huh yeah
so that's the kind of that's some boss i
love how nick knew
i probably i
googled king of england jacking off
comecatcher sure boom
wow is that a real thing yeah that was
somebody's gig
i think like that that seems like i
think chris's real color is true it's
hard under your eyes that's who you
that's your real color
and the and the rouge that you have to
put on to just
summer's coming up i'm gonna get tan of
[ __ ] you're almost like a red hat
you must have a vitamin d deficiency so
i have good tan i get good tan
i get good tags body change what your
face doesn't no my whole [ __ ] goes
[ __ ] crazy i look great at your face
i've never seen you tan dude it's like
people think doing this you know what
you know he's white face year-round but
your body's chocolate
you show you know what when i sit down
christmas and i get some sun and i
[ __ ] chill and when i get spray if
you want me to get sprayed and show you
instantly yeah i look great okay and my
[ __ ] looks it's like when you see me tan
you get it you're like oh okay because
it's unfair because it's unfair i don't
believe so we've got to make sure he's
white all the time otherwise it's unfair
i don't believe i don't believe it i
don't believe i don't think you tan well
at all okay well i'll tell you what dude
we need to see this we'll see what's up
in july no we'll tell you what by july
i'm gonna come in for one of these king
of the sting in the wing episodes and
i'm gonna [ __ ] look so good and i'm
gonna also be like i just i got this
workout session i'm doing tonight dude
crazy
crazy no no no no you're gonna come in
with noxzema on your forehead and you're
gonna be like it's a whole thing i was
outside in the sun and then you're gonna
be like you're gonna be like this is
it's a [ __ ] man it's a whole thing i
don't wanna get into it with sunshades
on like i'm so sorry my forehead is just
burnt do you do you get dark eric
yeah yeah i can tan oh yeah
you know everybody wants to if the rays
get past the [ __ ] hair
yeah go ahead
ideas
is that it nick that's it hi kids
phoenix is in phoenix celebrity theater
crystalia.com go to phoenix yup and i
will be in phoenix april 14th through
the 16th that stand up live with the
squad chapelle lacy will be with me and
then also april 22nd through 23rd i'm
headline moon tower comedy festival at
cap city the new cap city
two shows friday two shows saturday and
then the big boy april 28th my special
drops on sick boy youtube get you some
yeah
lol comedy club san antonio and houston
coming up check it out yes love you guys
see ya
it's the king and the sting
[Music]
and the sting and the wings
you